la sphère patrick 10 cet homme de 31 ans
condamné souvenez vous une seconde fois
récemment en assises pour le meurtre de
deux enfants en 1986 et qui a fait appel
il a demandé sa mise en liberté
provisoire en attendant son prochain
jugement
il s'est toujours déclaré innocent mais
n'a jamais convaincu les jurés et
l'avocat général de la cour d'appel de
lyon a requis ce matin son maintien en
détention
les parents de patrick dils espère
malgré tout yasmina farber thierry
breton patrick a changé d'avis plus de
lunettes plus de moustache et cheveux
courts
transféré de la maison d'arrêt de reims
ils arrivent détendus pour cette
audience devant la chambre d'instruction
de lyon c'est sa deuxième demande de
mise en liberté
à 31 ans dils a passé plus de 14 ans
derrière les barreaux pour le meurtre de
deux enfants qu'il conteste la défense s
car sa libération pour préparer son
troisième grand celland que je voulais
c'est un garçon qui n'a quand même pas
beaucoup évolué en prison parce que la
prison n'est pas une structure
d'évolution mais imaginez le libre
connaissent un petit peu la vie et dans
des mains amies
ce garçon là sera transformé combien
complètement il est capable au sens
positif du terme
il développera sa personnalité peu
loquace devant la cour d'assises dès
mineurs de la marne
dils n'avait pas convaincu les jurés de
son innocence alors qu'ils bénéficiaient
fait exceptionnel d'un procès en
révision
il avait été condamné à 25 ans de prison
pour lé meurtre d'alexandre et de cyril
deux enfants de 8 ans pour leur famille
une mise en liberté serait une
provocation
si on l'a dit à ses parents là à deux
reprises par deux procès par deux jurys
différents que patrick dils était bien
le coupable et qu'il était bien
assassins de leurs enfants
alors comment il voulait vous
qu'aujourd'hui il accepte remis en
liberté l'avocat général a requis le
maintien en détention de patrick 10 la
chambre d'instruction dira mardi
prochain s'il peut comparaître libre en
avril 2002 pour son troisième procès en
assises
une première dans les annales
judiciaires